ce nouveau gloubi-boulga au poivre en
grains et une merveille
je vais me souvenir de la recette et je
m'en préparé un dès demain
quelle merveille
mais je rêve tu es encore là Casimir ah
oui je suis là et je viens même de faire
un repart succulent
tu sais bien que juste à donner
rendez-vous dans le jardin
pas du tout voyons j'ai rendez-vous à
2h30 il est à peine une heure alors j'ai
encore le temps de faire ma vaisselle de
tout ranger que dis-tu quasimir une
heure mais il est au moins trois heures
mais tu tu es en retard réellement quoi
regarde sur mon réveil
son réveil ne marche pas c'est évident
Juan ne marcherait-il pas parce que il
souhaite que je sois en retard
c'est pour toi c'est pour moi
allô
depuis bientôt une demi-heure
je suis en retard excuse-moi mais je
n'ai pas de montre alors je ne savais
pas du tout quelle heure il était bon ne
t'inquiète pas j'arrive tout de suite
enfin tu auras quand même pu me prévenir
c'est de ta faute enfin oh là là bon
maintenant Julie va être furieuse bon
moi j'y vais tout de suite
allons allons oui Julie oui je t'appelle
pour te dire que ce n'est pas de la
faute de Casimir s'il est en retard non
non il est très ennuyé oui et tu sais
j'ai pensé comme c'est bien tôt ça fait
est-ce que tu ne crois pas
oui
Mademoiselle Julie je vous salue facteur
vous vous motorisez maintenant
Mademoiselle Julie je vous demande
pardon mais vous employez un mot
impropre
pour que je sois motorisé il faudrait
que juste un engin avec un moteur et ma
bicyclette n'en possède pas excusez-moi
je vous empêche pas grave non mais pour
bien se faire comprendre il faut
employer le mot qui convient exactement
voilà évidemment ça vous avez tout à
fait raison mais quel est le mot que
j'aurais dû employer oh mais c'est très
simple voyons voyons je suis sur une
bicyclette donc je me suis
bicycleté voilà
ça fait un peu bizarre
attendez une bicyclette s'appelle
également un vélo siped et bien voilà je
me suis vélocité
ça ça fait un peu drôle aussi ça va ça
va pas
eu de bicyclette possède à c'est vrai
les pédales mais voilà je me suis
pénalisé ouh là là ça va pédalisé non
ma bicyclette possède un guidon donc
voilà ça y est je ne suis guidolisé ça
c'est encore plus curieux alors ça va
encore pas bon
ah non j'avoue que c'est c'est dur de
trouver une expression simple pour une
situation ça c'est
où vous êtes mis en vélo
pendant Casimir répète un petit peu ce
que tu viens de dire j'ai dit vous vous
êtes mis en vélo c'est une expression
simple nous oh ben ça oui alors
je vais aller faire un petit peu de
sieste j'en ai besoin parce que je me
suis fatigué merci Casimir
au vélo bonne sieste
excuse-moi Julie si je suis en retard
mais je n'ai vraiment pas vu passer
l'heure ce n'est pas grave mais tu sais
je commençais à me faire du souci je me
demandais si tu étais malade c'est pour
ça que j'ai téléphoné dis-moi qu'est-ce
que tu faisais t'y apportant pour avoir
oublié l'heure de notre rendez-vous
passionnant comme un prêté François
je voulais simplement que nous répétions
notre dent c'est pour ça que je t'ai
donné rendez-vous à 2h30 mais maintenant
c'est trop tard j'ai un rendez-vous très
important avec Monsieur bauchen alors ça
sera pour une autre fois à tout à
l'heure
une autre fois oui enfin si au moins
j'avais une montre et bien cela ne
serait pas arrivé
tu as apporté ce que je t'ai demandé le
voilà
qu'est-ce que c'est ce sont des nougats
à la pistache voilà
comme Casimir n'est jamais à l'heure
parce qu'il n'a pas de montre Léonard et
moi nous avons pensé lui offrir pour sa
fête
ceci
je suis bouleversée ont vraiment c'est
trop gentil vous vous êtes de vrais amis
bonne fête
merci
je vais tout de suite aller me remercier
Léonard également et maintenant je
pourrais lui prouver que son vieux
réveil est toujours en retard merci
[Musique]
saucisson de potiron est une merveille
quelle odeur
il est encore très tôt non je crois pas
avec François oui alors
sauce
à mon réveil il est déjà 4h30 comment
4h30 pas possible donc je n'ai pas
confiance en ton vieux réveil non je
crois plutôt ma montre
ma montre
je ne comprends pas elle était là
tellement peu de soins qu'il te faut
absolument une chaîne pour attacher ma
montre
j'ai une idée tiens pendant que tu la
cherches je vais m'absenter quelques
minutes tu attends j'ai une excellente
idée si tu veux mais enfin il faut
absolument que je retrouve ma montre
François non non rien de grave mais j'ai
perdu ma montre oui écoute j'arrive dès
que je l'aurais retrouvé merci oui
peut-être ah là voilà j'espère que
personne ne s'est assis dessus
non ça va elle marche tant mieux tout va
bien
à l'instant même regarde ce que je
t'apprends
une superbe chaîne de monde une chaîne
pour maman montre
merci
je la passe dans l'anneau
et comme ça tu ne peux plus la perdre
voilà merci
dans 2 minutes il sera 5 heures et
quasiment n'est toujours pas là double 4
un patiente pas voyons 4e
top il sera exactement top top top top
top 5
0 seconde
le facteur n'est pas là ah mais non
c'est vrai il a dû prendre du retard
dans sa tournée oh là là
je suis je suis épuisé et
celui qui
un verre
[Applaudissements]
figurez-vous que j'ai dû faire toute ma
tournée à pied en poussant ma bicyclette
[Musique]
on m'a volé ma chaîne